me and it's starting to rain here keep
getting that from time to time and if
you're wondering what the temperature is
it is dropping a little bit I know some
were saying that it's about up who is
saying it anyhow let's start out with a
for somebody was saying it earlier that
in Hawaii it's about ninety and another
one we're saying that it's about about
thirty two anyhow early or low 50s where
I'm at and rainy rainy and cold avoid
the rainy and cold situations so let's
do it I'm not making it up this is
called the fantasy variation yes it is
no joke it's also at least on chess cube
being referenced as the tart to Cour
variation so I try to rattle off those
names in case you could are you're
wanting to learn more about them
especially those that are looking to
improve their own opening repertoire and
you find maybe certain openings
appealing to you maybe you can be
researching them for example that a last
game that Kings in the era can see Kings
gambit accepted if that was appealing to
you you definitely want to look that one
up because I offered no good advice with
that one and well what you do here I'm
not used to seeing such an early strike
at the center hmm well isn't that
different my first thought was just play
d5 my second thought is not play d5
about c3 and if chop chop I have still
the center of course if I play this move
my knight isn't gonna be too happy about
things and I'm gonna need to know how to
reorganize my Queen side pieces if I
have a pond occupying c3 give a check I
don't know what that accomplishes if I
play d5 well let's go with it is it okay
for white to claim at this point some
advantage just because I have a pond
this far advanced on the black side it's
not just that it's a pond that is
influencing this knight's deployment
it's typical squares taken away so
there's something that black is needing
to chew on what are they gonna do with
these two guys should the pond capture
and I believe it's best to do that so
that the bishop could see the world
after pawn captures I recapture like
this it is a past pond and can certainly
with just a single move turn into a
connected past pond with just c4
so
I did that d5 move because I wanted to
gain some space make some have some
inconvenience placed on black take away
c6 passed pawn this is an important
square right away
you can't just let this pawn get out of
control and get to d6 maybe d7 but
anyhow blockade and the ideal piece to
blockade is one of the Knights but I'm
not so sure that's gonna happen this is
gonna have to compete the move to run
with so do I play C for Knight c3 c4 and
then 93 or 93 right away honestly I like
playing c4 that way I'm not that way
none of my pieces by pieces I'm
referring to those other than pawns my
pieces will not be having to watch over
this pawn pawns should be watching over
pawns my knight could play to c3 my
bishop could play here seeing that black
is just tombs away before throwing a
rook on the e-file I want to make
certain that my King is also out of
harm's way I guess after castling and
having this half open file this could
turn out to be quite annoying a bishop
throwing itself on g5 placing black and
a pin now there is some pressure being
placed on each to I I don't have as mm I
was just really sad I'm not sort of
straight I have is safe a king side
since I since this F pawn is no longer
around but I have I mean there's good
things that I have as well as soon as
I'm Castle to my Rick is doing something
might I want to first check no I'm
seeing my king is being safer if I did
this the queen is gonna block I don't
want to do a Queen exchange I'm seeing
my king being safer I like that this
this right here has to be always watched
over I have a space advantage that's
another reason to maybe keep more pieces
on the board these are all little clues
all little clues and I think this is a
good move to be running with otherwise I
could be trying to remove this Bishop
Knight b5 pretty prevent maybe one day
there'll be an expansion with b5 in the
meantime what can what more can my queen
be doing or what more should she be
doing can we take it as far as that what
can she do maybe we should forget about
the word can what should she be doing
Bishop back Queen d3 Knight h4 to f5 hmm
hang on though Knight h4 is susceptible
to Queen out night here Knight here
would be putting pressure on this and my
Knights oh not so fast
maybe Queen c2 actually I like Queen c2
and it may seem a bit awkward to listen
to what I'm about to say next here but
I'm actually looking to do what I'm
looking to trade the light scrap bishops
I was just talking about not trading
pieces and then all of a sudden I think
it's good to trade pieces what did I
just can't keep I can't make up my mind
is that what it is that what's going on
here I guess it's a little bit of that
and also a little bit of recognizing
that this is my bad bishop
since I have pawns on these light
squares I think it would be a little bit
useful to get rid of the light square
bishop because he's the bad guy of my
two bishops additionally without this
light square bishop around my knight
would be able to rely upon that f5
square once on f5 he's gonna turn into
the big bad wolf
now since this knight can't make use of
g4 maybe Knight h4 to f5 is available
although after Knight H for Queen to c7
there's pressure on H to push here
there's a check it's a little bit scary
yeah I should just play here follow
through with what I said
let's get those bishops off well one I
think having one pair of minor pieces
off the board get these guys off and
then it's a little bit easier to follow
through with the night h4 f5 idea one
minute each let's go here one minute
warning we are only 13 moves in but a
lot of stuff was happening quickly so
the bishop pair is mine so what does
that really matter here umm this Knights
ready to play here I might want to take
care give it right back
let's do it the Queen the knight needs
to take I think it's tempting to take
with the Queen but Knight takes Bishop
takes pawn I went upon ok I think I'm
winning upon there's probably Knight
rook takes Knight first but there's no
no time to figure it out h2 is
unprotected I'm viewing this h2 squares
being unprotected does anybody know why
I posted a video about this this very
idea why exactly in my mind I'm viewing
h2 is being unprotected even though I
have my king protecting it there's a
trivia for you alright let's just react
by playing here I didn't want to play
here cuz I want to be able to shift my
Queen over and I think shifting Yolo
right now is good ready to chop this
pawn let's do this
Queen trade I'm okay with and King
position I have this covered pawn push
they're in blitz mode blitz mode just
trade trade trade trade trade trade grab
pieces kill this Knight keep things real
simple get rid of that tricky Knight
okay I cut about my c4 pawn my knight
was defending the rook right there in
the ending can you realize that okay
good game let's hit that rewind button
backing up and hopefully take that thing
or two away hopefully I'll have more
something more to add here then then one
then the last game then the Kings are
the Kings gambit accepted game anyhow
okay so from your perspective here what
is the scoop fantasy variation I think
you'll want to look into the following
on this next move namely move four so if
you're gonna take I think you really
need to look into this
'if I've advanced that's my first
suggestion maybe my best suggestion
right now instead of East sixth is so
much less concern I have if you're
playing east six right now because well
why am I saying that I'm saying that
because I don't have to worry about your
Bishop maybe coming out to bother me
he's he's of no bother to me if you're
playing east six right away so can
consider 'if I've striking at this
center and there still I believe quite a
bit you're needing to know even after
playing e5 because a natural move is
Knight f3 I would think the majority of
players would go with this in response
to e5 after eat takes D then I believe
Bishop c4 turns out to be quite strong
so I think there might be something like
e 5 and after Knight f3
I think Bishop e6 might be the move I
cannot be certain knowing that if from
the
takes the pond there's this queen out to
h4 move
and if pawn takes pawn well the Queens
can come off and maybe there's a way
that you could just be getting those
double pawns back and then work against
white having an isolated e pond I'm not
a hundred percent on this but I'm pretty
sure about this 'if I move on this move
for instead of b6 okay that said we end
up with this structure you do end up
striking at it with now c5 but it does
take two moves in order to get that in
something tells me that this position
could somehow come about in another line
where when c5 is played it's coming in
just one move but you're having to take
those two steps before it arrives on c5
seeing how your very first move was c6
so I have a connected passed pawn I
think this is a good idea right here a
six keeping a close eye on this block
hater because the typical idea is when
your opponent is blockading your own
pond to try and remove the block haider
so you're renewing the possibility for
advancing your pawn I don't know if
there's I don't know if I gave you a
window of opportunity anywhere it's very
difficult to work around this now
because of these structural changes
because of the earlier decisions to
maybe run with e6 and c5 it's once once
again my attention is drawn to the
structure and the position the pawns and
how once again how the pawns in chess
are going to really act as the blueprint
for the remainder or not the remainder
but just the rest of your the rest of
your pieces it's there the instruction
manual day they let you know what the
rest of your pieces should be doing and
I don't know that you have a good plan
to be going with with this current
structure getting your pieces out if you
take my light square Bishop you're
bringing my queen in so I it's
understandable like why you would maybe
want to take out my knight and have to
deal with maybe just my bishop instead
of my knight and stuff like that but I
believe I end up still standing bad
maybe maybe the best the best try is
going to be do recaptured the night
maintain the material and then try to
get it here but even so I think this is
still pretty good for white I have the
the rooks are working and these guys are
still looking for a job right here so I
think just coming all the way back
consider that a five move at this very
early stage instead of instead of e6
looking this efj I've a bit more